So, now that we know that the cache is
a small memory inside our processor
where we are trying to find the data
before we go to the main memory.
Let's take some time and
recap what we need out of cache.
We need it to be fast.
Which means it has to be small.
Because it's small,
not everything will fit.
There will be a lot of memory
locations that we do not have room for
in our cache.
So when a processor wants to access
some memory, we can have a cache hit,
which occurs when we find what
we are looking for in the cache.
The memory location we are interested in
was already brought from the memory to
the cache before.
So now we're accessing it, and
we can just find it in the cache.
And the access is then very quick,
so this is what we want.
We want fast accesses for
most of our memory accesses,
and that happens when we
have a lot of cache hits.
But because the cache is very small and
not everything fits in it,
we can also have a cache miss.
This happens when what we're looking for
is not in the cache, and in that case,
we have to access the slow memory.
When we have a cache miss, we want to
copy this location to the cache so
that next time we access it, and
hopefully we will because of locality,
we will have a cache hit.
So it is necessary to have cache misses
because that's how we really bring
stuff into the cache
in order to have hits.
The more locality we have,
the more cache hits we will have and
the fewer cache misses.
Because one miss will bring
the data into the cache and
then hopefully we will use it many,
many times.
When we a cache miss, that is slow,
that access is going to take some time.
But that should happen very rarely.
Most of the time when we need something,
we find it in the cache.
Or, at least we hope to do that.
And we want to design our caches so
that that's how it works.